jerry's in portland oregon
hi jerry how are you doing great dave
how are you today
better than i deserve what's up hey so
i'm coming today to figure out
uh where i need to go in the baby steps
i've already finished baby step
one and i've saved a thousand dollars in
my savings account um but i have sixty
thousand debt
uh one is my car one is a motorcycle
that's now posted on craigslist for sale
um and then the rest is collections um
which is about thirty to forty thousand
um
i'm sorry it's twenty thousand uh some
of the accounts and collections
are between five and six years old woman
where
do those fall in line with uh
the baby steps and what gets paid off
first gotcha
jerry as you talk about this how much of
the 60 is the car
uh it's about 19 000. okay and the
motorcycle is how much
18 000. okay and you've already got that
listed for sale
any other active debts outside of of of
the stuff that's in collections
no nothing else is and i'm a veteran so
i've gone to college for free
okay on the gi bill so i don't have any
student loan debts i don't have any
credit card debt um because that's gone
to collections years ago
okay and i just finally got a new job uh
working at high risk security
uh where it's actually finally paying me
longer than i've ever made
in my life what do you make i make sixty
thousand dollars a year good for you
good for you and so have you verified
these these debts that are in
collections do you have letters from the
companies are they calling you
they're calling me yes okay all right so
with this you know in dealing with these
these collectors i'm sure you've dealt
with all different types you'll have
those that try to be your friend
others that'll try to strong arm you you
know the main thing is
is first and foremost is to ask for debt
verification
that means they're going back and double
checking and understanding exactly and
verifying what you know
for sure that you owe and then once you
get those in writing just in looking at
those
it's really a matter of following the
debt snowball you're going to attack it
but here's a little difference in the
nuance they will come to you and they'll
start trying to offer you what's called
a settlement offer
as you speak with them and they'll start
to ask you questions about the money you
have so be very guarded
in your answer just find out what
they're willing to accept
and dave we found they're willing to
sometimes take pennies on the dollar
yeah generally especially on that old
stuff so to answer your
your front end question jerry yeah sell
the motorcycle and get the car paid off
before you worry about it
the stuff that's in collections don't
worry about it once a car once the car
is paid off the motorcycle's gone then
the only thing you've got left are old
bad debts correct correct
then we're going to list those smallest
to largest
and you're going to settle each one of
those in a lump sum
no payments okay and so give me an
example of one of your debts
that is old um
i've got an old electricity bill from uh
whenever i lived in
actually portsmouth tennessee okay and
how old is that
about a hundred it is five years old and
it's about 139 dollars
okay that one and we're screwing with
you'll just get them on the phone
verify the amount and pay them okay
that's that's probably one of your
smallest ones
then you've got the one that's five
thousand dollars it's a credit card from
10 years ago or five years ago right
yes something like that now that one you
they're gonna when you get in touch with
them
you owed them four thousand dollars now
years later they're gonna
have added collections fees and interest
and late charges and a bunch of other
things
you can settle that for probably below
what the original debt was
in a lump sum so let's use a pretend
number let's say it was originally five
thousand you get a hold of them now it's
twelve thousand
so i would offer them three or four cash
yeah and they'll take it not immediately
there'll be some wrangling and some
wrestling and some so forth but
eventually they will take it
and get it in writing once you get an
acceptance
and do not allow them to remove it
directly from your checking account
because they lie they will clean out
your checking account yes
and take the improper amount out it's a
really
dirty business
okay yeah jerry and i want i would tell
you to get a cashier's check when you
get ready to pay it
make a copy of that check along with the
letter of settlement that they've
offered you
keep that in your file or a prepaid
debit card that you only use for one
transaction and throw it away
and you use that transaction but you
keep a hard copy
of the settlement offer of three
thousand dollars
and then proof that you sent them the
three thousand dollars because they lie
they'll come back after you two years
from now so you still owe money
right right and if you don't keep
documentation on this like it's a dadgum
court case
you're gonna be you're gonna regret it
thank you for your service brother
we appreciate it and dave you know
another thing i found with this people
in our military really have to be
careful
because having collections it can mess
with their security clearance
yeah and he's no longer in it right but
he's in his high-risk security in the
same situation they may
come back on him in that but yeah we see
the uh the third
largest reason for dishonorable
discharge in the military is debt
money problem money problems because you
lose your security clearance and you
lose the
uh you know the the the really the
confidence of command
is what it amounts to and um they they
it's it's a
real problem and you know we've all
heard of the
uh for instance the guys and gals that
are in the high risk in the battlefield
scenarios how high the suicide rate is
but the suicide rate is also tied to
relational problems back home
and money problems back home right and
could mix that with battle yeah and you
have a really dangerous psychological
mix
that's terrible so we work with these
guys all over the world and um
the guys in command gals in command know
that if they can get their team
um whether it's military or otherwise
any team thinking about the mission
rather than their money problems it's uh
it's less dangerous for everyone
involved
it changes so you're driving a forklift
thinking about your problems with your
money it's dangerous
it really is and so if you're a company
out there and you go
boy you're just kind of looking and
realizing your team is struggling
smart dollar is the program that we have
that will walk your team through the
process
just go to smartdollar.com uh it's
lessons on there that are taught by dave
myself and rachel
your team will be able to focus and be
more productive on their job
by you giving them this kind of help
again that's smartdollar.com